daniel in texas here on the bench bureau
she'll go for it daniel
yeah thanks man um i have a question but
it takes a little explanation this
weekend there was a
event that solidified with me that i
need to have a carry license
and be carrying we were driving down the
road and the guy made a uh
took a random shot at our vehicle with
my kids in it
i was just wondering what would happen
if i'd been carrying and i had returned
fire and hit it
well if you're under deadly threat and
you act in self-defense to
prevent a threat to yourself or your
child then you'd be okay um if you hit
somebody else in the process
then you'd be in in trouble presumably
um but
again self-defense is still the law
across the united states it really
doesn't matter the location if you're
walking down the street and someone
takes a shot at you and you defend
yourself then you'd basically
be all right but you know obviously i
don't know where you were what event
this was that sounds pretty dangerous
daniel i appreciate the call stay safe
out there
ariel in dublin california on the ben
shapiro show ariel rather welcome to the
bench pressure i'll go for an area
hi man i'm a big fan um now i don't want
to assume your gender
but i don't think you were a preteen
girl in the late 80s like i was
i was there and the babysitter's club
was one yeah the babysitter club was one
of the biggest book series at that time
and it was one of my favorites and when
i heard netflix was making a new tv
series i was really looking forward to
watching with my girls
and then i found out they made the whole
series woke including an entire episode
on transgenderism and
i just think this is one of the most
insidious examples of straight up
indoctrination in media towards kids and
i'm afraid my girls are going to be
taught
that their gender is whatever they want
it to be and shows like this make
sounding like changing your sex is no
big deal when in reality
it involved medicalizing mutilating and
sterilizing children
but they never discussed that part yep
it is uh that is exactly right it is
amazing
how children's programming has been
infused with all the social justice
warrior messaging
nonsense i mean they haven't gotten to
the preschool stuff yet although they're
trying to ban paw patrol
but the pre-teen stuff particularly they
really are loading up with an enormous
amount of social justice warrior
messaging you can see this
for example abc used to have a channel
called abc family
it used to be called abc family and now
i believe it's called freeform they
shifted it because they wanted it to be
more progressive they wanted to be more
edgy and they changed their content over
right there's a channel that used to
sort of air old episodes of the waltons
and now it would do stuff like gossip
girl because it wanted to push
particular viewpoints on on humanity the
notion that you're going to
ladle in transgenderism into the
babysitter's club which as you say is is
really not directed toward 25 year old
people who can
consider the arguments but it's directed
toward 11 and 12 year olds
it's fully insane and it is propaganda
there's no question i mean i i seriously
doubt
that any of this tv show was about the
costs of
of gender transformation uh or the
regret
or the fact that you actually can't
change your gender
or about any of the any of the myriad
deleterious effects
one of the big problems with
transgenderism has been well documented
by
by my friend abigail schreier she has a
book out right now that's worthy of the
read
is something called rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is a situation in which
particularly
pre-teen girls are being convinced that
they may in fact be transgender when in
fact they are just depressed or unhappy
or have another mental condition
and what you can see is that one girl in
a group of girls
who are simultaneously experiencing some
sort of issue but not transgenderism not
gender dysphoria
if one of them declares their gender
dysphoric then suddenly a lot of them
declare they are gender dysphoric and
this is why you've seen a radical shift
statistically speaking from gender
dysphoria being diagnosed in men
biological men and biological boys to
gender dysphoria
overwhelmingly now in places like
britain being diagnosed in
young girls who are declaring themselves
gender dysphoric and because gender
dysphoria
doesn't really have a supremely solid
definition
then being listened to being given
hormone therapy being given treatments
and parents being banned from being able
to
stop them from doing any of this stuff
in the name of of social justice and
wokeness
and and sympathy so yeah i mean this
stuff is
ugly it's propaganda i mean i hope that
nobody watches it then i mean if they're
going to ladle in a bunch of leftist
propaganda on gender which does have
some
damaging ramifications for people again
i'm not going to be teaching my daughter
that she can become a boy nor will i be
teaching my son that he can become a
girl
though those are those that is a value
judgment that is anti-science
and you know if somebody suffers from
gender dysphoria like truly suffers from
gender dysphoria
i wish them nothing but the best i wish
them the best in their treatment and
when they're adults if they decide that
they want to make decisions that i think
might not be right but are right for
them then it's a free country but if you
think that
anybody should be going along with the
idea that 11 year olds should be getting
hormone treatments or
that 11 year olds instead of wait for
watching which is the strategy
that basically says we wait we watch and
we see what happens instead of pursuing
that we push the idea that we are
supposed to
reaffirm your new gender that that's
insanity if that's being pushed by the
entertainment community that's nothing
but propaganda
well i just want to say that what's
really crazy about this show is that
netflix rated it g so normally when you
have parental controls
like if it was rated pg then you would
not be able to see it if you only wanted
your kids to cg so the only way parents
can keep
this show away from their girls from
just their account is they have to
literally go into their netflix account
and there's a way for you to say like i
don't want any of this show on my
account
so they have to delete it completely
from like their entire platform
but most people don't know that and most
people think oh the babysitter's club i
love the babysitter's club what a
wholesome show
but it's not it's teaching girls some
really dangerous
ideas about themselves that in if they
think is
right for them can lead to the road of
like sterilizing them when they're
teenagers it's crazy it is crazy and i'm
glad that you brought it up i hope that
hopefully
hopefully this you know you've brought
some more attention to it and hopefully
listeners to the show now recognize what
exactly is implicit
in in the show that's that's pretty
terrifying stuff ariel i really
appreciate the call thanks for the
information
samantha and denver colorado you're on
the bench should go for it samantha
hi ben great to talk to you um
yeah so i attended a um pro police rally
in denver on sunday
um we were met with a black lives matter
slash antifa
activist protest and several of our
rally-goers were beaten and attacked
and i myself had you know a big guy get
in my face and repeatedly
threatened to slit my throat um so it
was it was insane
so it was mostly peaceful it was mostly
peaceful according to the media right
right right right and wondering why we
were attacking these
these peaceful protesters um so
you know it uh it's it's crazy but i
you know i think a lot of people you
know especially on kind of the right
side of the aisle are wondering
you know should we continue to have
these events should we continue to even
try to stand up for our patriotism
patriotism and supporter officers um and
try to stand up for american values
if there's a sort of a protest because a
lot of people don't want to be faced
with this but
you know i i'm just i don't want to
invite people
into a dangerous situation but at the
same time like
you know should we still be standing up
for
um for america for our country i mean i
think what you're doing is deeply
important i i can never you know tell
people that they should
risk life and limb by going to a rally
in the united states but
you know what you're doing is really
important the fact again the media are
lying about so much of the stuff the
media trying to
suggest that if you crack down on riding
and looting you're actually
cracking down on on protesting if you
crack down on violence you're actually
cracking down on mostly peaceful
protesters
the media have just been derelict in
their in their coverage of this sort of
stuff and it really is
maddening and insane as far as you know
personal decisions to to either back off
or show your support
listen i think that more of us standing
up and showing support for the police
is absolutely necessary at this time are
you gonna watch your community go down
the train i mean we're seeing this
already in los angeles
where the murder rate is up we're seeing
in new york and chicago you're doing
absolutely the right thing but
we can't pretend that the the media are
either going to treat this with any
amount of objectivity
or frankly that even the police are
being emboldened and empowered to
protect you if god forbid something bad
happens at these places because the
political actors have basically told the
police hands off
with a lot of these protests right even
while they they go ahead and commit acts
of violence so it's
it's pretty incredible so samantha what
was the ending of it i mean was anybody
you know really injured um there was one
of our our main
um organizers of the event he was hit in
the head i
okay i think it was with a long board
and he ended up with you know a big gash
across his forehead
um some of our others you know that the
protesters had collapsible batons that
they were walking around with um there
were a couple other people that
were shoved downstairs and ended up with
bumps and bruises um you know and and
that's exactly with the police officers
they were told by our local
you know mayor and governor to stand
down and to not engage so they were
nearby but um
it really had to come down to somebody
actually being physical assault
physically assaulted for them to step in
oh amazing stuff samantha thanks for
doing what you're doing and uh
stay safe out there i mean if you can
really appreciate it amy in seattle
you're on the bench i'll go forward amy
hi good morning i wanted your advice
regarding navigating cancel culture as a
young conservative woman
living in seattle i frequently see
family and friends posting
misinformation
and skewed statistics on social media
and i want to provide the actual facts
i am a cpa at a big four accounting firm
and i would never want to jeopardize my
career
by getting cancelled for speaking the
truth so my question would be
how do i balance speaking out on
important issues today like black lives
matter and deepening the police while
being careful as to not lose my job
yeah i mean it's very very difficult to
me uh and honestly i can't
actually suggest that social media is
the best way to do this uh i think that
interpersonal conversation
is probably better social media the
problem is that anything can be taken
out of context and used against you
people can act as though they are
offended when they are not
it's an ugly cancel culture out there so
i've never
advised people that it is their duty to
speak up when it means
losing their job and not being able to
support their family i think that that's
a personal choice that everybody has to
make but certainly the
the possibility of cancelled culture is
is out there i mean i was just reading a
story a few moments ago
about a story about a school teacher who
was fired for the great sin of saying
president
trump is our president literally that's
all he said and he got fired for it so
we're now living in a world where you
can get canceled for everything
and and anything so if you value your
job don't count on your bosses to stand
up for you because i really really doubt
they will i mean this is this is the
story of the last several years in the
united states is people
basically manipulating bosses into
firing people that they don't like and
if you fall into that yeah there's not
much you can do about it unfortunately
so all i would recommend is that if
you're going to have conversations with
people do it
offline because that way it becomes more
of a
you telling the truth and the other
person fibbing about what you said to
them conversation as opposed to
here's a post that i found particularly
offensive because you didn't put a black
square on your twitter or something
right thank you amy i really appreciate
hanging there seattle
not a great place to live at this point
in time derek in chicago illinois you're
on the bench shapiro show how's it going
derek
ben i love you man thanks for uh you
know speaking out so much man
and i just want to encourage you to keep
on the good path man but uh
i just wanted to ask you uh do you think
number one do you think weed
is a sin and number two what do you
think about lori uh light put in chicago
that whole uh fifth grade behavior stuff
between her and trump what do you make
of that
well she's a terrible mayor i mean i
don't know what else to say about a
person
who's spending all of her time ripping
on the police while dozens of people get
shot in her city every every weekend
and she she's just awful at her job the
fact that she's blaming republicans and
lack of gun control for violence in
chicago is patently insane
i mean frankly jared you may be the only
person left in chicago who hasn't been
shot and i'm making an assumption here
so it's it's pretty wild
one last thing ben uh would you think uh
you'd ever do howard stern man because i
think that'd be a great interview
well if yes we'll consider it i
appreciate it derek